[Musica]
molto fresco
forse ancora
[Musica]
era rosa talvolta con me imburratori
che non rimani mai fatti uscire mi
davanti sogno La Romanina ora che
ritrovi la via ma a volte sei solo
[Musica]
che non rimane mai fatti
quando mi piaceva stare dietro nella
vista bagagliaio per me tutta la
campagna la concentrazione si fa
un'altra faccia però la vecchia Poi ti
manca cambiare a gas quanto mi piaceva
disegnare starmi sulla spiaggia ora le
mie ali sulla plancia Pietra Lunare sui
miei guai mi evolvono con me Dragona
[Musica]
ed extra Roma
la mia pazienza Non è una sorgente drago
che sorride non si perde fatto troppe
cose per buttarmi giù
passo dalla fatica
unirà che non è mia
non rimani mai fatti mi rendi davanti
sono l'anomalia
non è sicura la Via
Lattea
che non rimane mai fatti
quando mi piace passare dietro nella
Volvo già 40 vista bagagliaio per me la
concentrazione si fa un'altra faccia
però la vecchia fatto
mi piaceva l'idea
girare
vado un po' di casino per plastica
Grazie
per allontanare siete guai
[Musica]
ed ex Roma ora
vola vola vola vola
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Io voglio guardarmi davvero
Voglio ricordarti sul serio
[Musica]
io non vedo più i bordi sento questi
accordi e sembra mi parli ma sempre di
te
sembra che parli sempre di te
[Musica]
quanto mi sento bene quanto mi sento
male se non Mantengo la calma Ti giuro
mantengo la fame quanto mi sento bene
quanto mi sento male se non Mantengo la
calma Ti giuro mantengo la fame quanto
mi sento bene quanto mi sento male se
non Mantengo la calma Ti giuro mantengo
la fame quanto mi sento bene quanto mi
sento male se non Mantengo la calma Ti
giuro mantengo la fame
[Musica]
non tengo la fame
nessuno riesce a calmarmi io non so a
cosa aggrapparmi niente riesce a
calmarmi io non so a cosa aggrapparmi
prima o poi mi passerà
l'anima mi basta che
non tengo la fame
mantengo la fame
[Musica]
fame fame fame fame
fame fame pane pane
faccio un salto al mare Sono mantengo
l'account Ti giuro ma il tempo la fame
plastica
[Applauso]